tennis great novak djokovic confirmed he
is not vaccinated for covid an issue
that got him barred from the australian
open last month he told our partners at
the bbc that he's ready to skip the next
two grand slam tournaments
vaccines are still required chris
livesay has more from from that
exclusive interview chris good morning
good morning michelle that's right novak
djokovic breaking his silence but not
his convictions the world's greatest
men's tennis player says he's willing to
give it all up for his right to refuse
the vaccine
no one likes winning more than novak
djokovic but not says the 20-time grand
slam champion at any cost
are you prepared to forego
the chance to be the greatest player
that ever picked up a racket
statistically
because you feel so strongly about this
jab
yes
i do
why no
why why because the principles of uh
decision making on my body are more
important than any title
foregoing his legacy in order to forego
the vaccine in january he was set to
travel down under for the australian
open to defend his title for the fourth
time the only problem australia requires
vaccination to enter have you received
any vaccination against covid
i have not but the serbian superstar
received an exemption because he says he
tested positive for kovitt in december
however upon arrival authorities
questioned unforced errors on his
paperwork finally after 11 days of back
and forth he was deported by the
immigration minister on health and good
order grounds is it good to be home it
was a dramatic grand finale in a country
that lived through one of the toughest
and longest lockdowns in the world more
than 80 percent of australians agreed he
should be kicked out but to the growing
anti-vax movement around the world the
tennis champion had become a champion of
their cause whether he liked it or not
what do you say directly to
anti-vaccination campaigners around the
world who proudly declare
novak djokovic is one of us
i say that everyone has the right to to
choose to act or say whatever they feel
is appropriate for them
and i have never said that i'm part of
that movement he doesn't oppose all
vaccines but he refused the covet
vaccine in the interest of not
interfering with his intense athletic
conditioning a right to choose he
defends for all it's really the
principle of understanding what is right
and what is wrong for you and me as an
elite professional athlete i've always
carefully reviewed assessed everything
that comes in from the supplements food
the water that i drink or sports drinks
anything really that
comes into my body as a fuel
that can
that i can benefit from if this means
that you miss the french open
is that a price you'd be willing to pay
yes there is the price that i'm willing
to pay and if it means that you miss
wimbledon this year again that's a price
you're willing to pay yes
now the us also requires vaccination in
order to enter the country so he risks
missing the u.s open as well when asked
if he would reconsider getting the
vaccine djokovic said his mind remains
open vlad
all right chris lives safe for us in
rome thank you very much
can't get mad at him for standing up for
his convictions but he can't be mad if
states and tennis organizations say you
can't participate uh you can get
confused because 25 50 years from now
he's just going to be a name on a
graphic at a tennis tournament is going
to say he's not the greatest and does he
really want that aren't you playing for
early i want to know what he's reading
what data what science i want to know
what he's basing this belief on because
i think that would clear up a lot for us
i don't think that yeah i think that's
going to be a pile of question mark
i just keep a question mark we'll see